Let's say you want to transfer a file
from one computer to another and it is
really important to know that it's
got there intact in one piece
erm, you could send it multiple times and
then compare them all - but what generally
gets used is something called a hash
algorithm.
A hash algorithm is kind of
like the check digit in a bar code on a
credit card. I think James Grime talked
about this a long long time ago on Numberphile. The last digit in a bar code or on a
credit card is determined by all the
other digits on it and if you change one
of those digits
the last one changes as well so as you
typed into a computer
- you can know instantly if you've
missed a key somewhere
so a hash algorithm is kind of like that
- but for an entire file that might be
megabytes or gigabytes in size
what it gives you is a code 16 or 32 or
64 characters generally hexadecimal
basically just one long number expressed
in that way that is a "sum up" of
everything that's in that file
If you crushed it down if you do all
these manipulations to it and crush it down
crush it down and crush it down and what it
comes out with this thing that says this is
a summary of that file you can never
make it work backwards you can't pull
that data back out but it's like a
signature
it's like a confirmation that this file
is really who it says it is the simplest
hash algorithm I can think of
I would just be something like that's
five
add up all the digits in the file
which is 4, 9, 14, 23 that's not a good hash
algorithm for a few reasons
hash algorithms have three main
requirements the first one is speed
it's got to be reasonably fast it should
be able to churn through a big file in in a
second or two at most
but it also shouldn't be too quick if
it's too quick it's easy to break and
I'll explain that later
the second requirement is that if you
change one byte one bit anywhere in the
file of the start of the middle at the
end then the whole hash should be
completely different this is something
called the avalanche effect. If
you're interested in how this is
achieved do look up the actual algorithms
themselves. It would take me an
hour to explain vaguely how they work
in a in a friendly way but if it's your
kind of thing do look it up but suffice
it to say one bit gets flipped anywhere
in the message then the whole hash is
completely and utterly different the
third requirement is that you've got to
be able to avoid what are called hash
collisions
this is where you have two documents
which have the same hash
obviously there is a mathematical
principle called the pigeonhole
principle you have it if you have 50
pigeons and 25 pigeonholes did you have
to stuff two pigeons into one of the
pigeonholes that's a terrible analogy
when you say it like this but if I could
explain it
there are incredible numbers of
documents out that possible with the
hash meanwhile it's just one fairly long
number that will be files out there
which naturally have the same hash and
that's okay because the odds against it
are so unlikely that we can deal with
that it's never going to happen
naturally
but if you can artificially create a
hash collision
if you can say create a file and change
your name
then we have a problem and that's that's
where security comes into these because
if i can make a file that sums to a
certain hash
then i can fake documents i can send
different things and have this signature
match
so let's say I have an important
document something that's i don't know, that's
the "permission to to go to the moon" I don't know why I said that erm...
oh yeah "permission to go to the moon"
let's say that - and it's got someone's name
on it
and that file is sent and along with it
through other channels comes this hash
to verify that this is actually the
document
now let's say I can intercept that file
and I can change it but because the hash
algorithm is broken i can change it and
change the name and change the data and
change whatever i can send someone else
to the moon because I can make this
hash the same through carefully tweaking the
bytes
now it's incredibly difficult to do that
in practice you'd want a massive file and a
lot of computer code but there are old
hash algorithms like md5 which was used
for many many years which now have these
collisions out in the wild and
are considered broken because you can get a
file not document with text in but a
computer code anything like that where
it's possible to send something
malicious and have it come out with the
same hash
so this is important this is where speed
comes it if the hash is too slow
no one will want to use it but if the
hash is too fast if you can create new
ones in a few processor cycles then you
can fairly easily create documents that
match a particular hash. it is in a very
real sense an arms race as I said for
many years md5 was the accepted
algorithm and it's still used for a few
things but md5 is now thoroughly
broken because computers are fast enough
and there are a few -sort-of- interesting
tricks you can use to try and create
hash collisions deliberately. The other
problem with md5 is because it was used
so much and it was used everywhere on
the web
google has become an exceptionally good
resource for breaking them
You wouldn't want to store a
password this way i'll talk about that
in a later video
don't use something like this for
storing passwords but people did many
for many years people did & in a lot of cases
a word will be stored next to its md5
hash for some reason if you type an md5
hash into google frequently the word it
was hashing comes out which means that
for pretty much every word in the
English language and a lot of other
passwords besides the md5 can be solved
by typing it into google
so md5 is is comprehensively,
constantly broken so everyone move to
something called sha-1 and now there are
rumors that that might start to be
broken soon if it hasn't already because
computers keep getting faster hash
collisions are easier to generate so
everyone is moving to sha-2 which for
the time being is secure. sha-3 is going through
the process of being ratified by all
the agencies now and in a few years
that'll be the standard - I mean
ultimately I should really
emphasize this **Don't use this for
storing passwords** I'll talk about that in
a later video
these are used for verifying files for
verifying transmission and that's all
they should be useful
there is one last thing which is that
occasionally you will see
download sites offering software who say
that
here's the file we're going to send you
and click here to download it and if you
want to be safe
here's the hash of the file so you can
be sure it's the right one
- that's a terrible idea I mean it will
verify you've gotta download intact but
they're selling this as we guarantee
that this software is safe and you can
check it against that hash - which is
a bad idea because if someone has been
able to get into their website and
change the software they're sending its
pretty trivial to change that hash as well so
they got that is hash algorithms that is
taking a big chunk of data and turn it
into a small amount to verify it & in a
later video i will talk about how that's
used and how that shouldn't be used for
actually keeping things secure
this episode of computer file was
brought to you by audible.com and you
can go to audible.com / computerphile
and download a free book
they've got a huge range that you can listen
to on all kinds of devices your phone or
in the car things like that
I was thinking about a book to recommend
and it made me think about the first
audio book I ever listened to and that was
Treasure Island and I listened to it on a
cassette next to my bed as i was going
to sleep each night I checked the
audible website they do have treasure
island
so that's my recommendation today why
don't you check it out
audible.com/computerphile free book and
thanks to them for supporting our videos